so this is our regression model and that what we want
to do is we want to assign it to assign it to a variable so
we can say let's say
linear model
You can call it whatever you want.
now let's
run this line of code
now there is a special function to plot.
The there's a special function that will take.
your model
and
extract from it or the camera
from it. It's slope. It's intercept and
Append appendellite on top
of your current graph it will give us that that you
know that visualization we're looking for. So if you want to see the
contents of your model the summary of your model, there's a
function called summary.
passed with your model run it
And I will give you some information about your regression model now some
of the things we haven't talked about like residuals.
the coefficients
it is significance levels and standard
error r squared F test F
statistics I had slides on those.
but let's quickly run through them and
maybe we can touch how these also now to plot.
The regression line on top of
this graph like just like put on top of it. There's
a function called a b line.
It takes a multiple arguments, but the primary one is of course
the
the leading model itself
There's a function called.
coefficient
and you want to pass through with your linear model. I'll tell you I'll tell you
about arguments of this function.
in the second example
and the second argument is simply if you want to cut by
default the color will be black but let's use red because
It will be the line will be clear.
Give it a color you can say, you know red.